ärgert in diesen tagen wie viele andere
menschen dann sicher auch das thema
afghanistan ist ärgert mich nicht nur
das macht mich sehr sehr traurig muss
ich will hier nicht pathetisch werden
aber wirklich sehr vielen weinen wenn
ich daran denke was in den letzten 20
jahren nicht gemacht wurde
gleichzeitig habe ich wie sie
wahrscheinlich alle auch mich in den
letzten tagen und wochen sehr damit
beschäftigt was eigentlich auch vor
diesen 20 jahren war und man stellt fest
schon fontane hat 18 69 über afghanistan
gedicht geschrieben oder helmut schmidt
hat schon sehr früh
analysen gemacht über afghanistan wie
schwierig es ist dieses land auch zu
demokratisieren oder überhaupt politik
zu betreiben nichtsdestotrotz bin ich
eine überzeugte demokratin und denke
wenn die alliierten die
großmächte die demokratie einbringen
wollten und so groß getönt haben die
frauen in afghanistan retten zu wollen
dann hätte ich schon erwartet dass sie
mit einem plan reingehen und zwar mit
einem sogenannten marshall plan wenn sie
es wirklich ernst gemeint hätten und
dass jetzt diese flucht akt dieses brot
fluchtartigen verlassen afghanistan dass
man uns das als überraschung serviert
und man hat es nicht gewusst und hätte
es nicht wissen können dass die taliban
schon so weit sind nun auch für mich
arbeiten menschen die aus afghanistan
stammen oder ihre familien ich kann
ihnen sagen wie wir vorhin von den
menschen da draußen oder drinnen
gesprochen haben also die einfachen
menschen auf der straße erzählen einem
schon seit jahren was in afghanistan los
ist und vielleicht hätten die
politikerinnen und politiker da einfach
mal mit dem taxifahrer sprechen sollen
oder mit einem bäcker um die ecke dann
hätten sie erfahren dass die teile waren
schon längst drin sind in den familien
und aus diesen familien heraus ihre
politik schon betrieben haben und
deshalb auch das land schneller anderem
konnten und das ist nur ein kleiner
ausschnitt und mit dem mit afghanistan
mit dem thema zusammen bringe ich hier
das thema migration und islam mit das
ist meine hauptthemen aktuell ich finde
dass wir einen sehr schwierigen
schwierigen kampf in den nächsten
jahrzehnten führen müssen gegen den
politischen islam ich denke dass der
politische islam eine der größten
herausforderungen unseres jahrhunderts
vielleicht ist sogar jahrzehnts
mindestens und dass wir eine politik
betreiben sollten die fernab von
rassismen funktioniert mich enttäuschen
unsere demokratischen parteien beim
thema migrationspolitik deshalb weil sie
nicht in der lage sind fernab von
rassismus
migrationspolitik zu thematisieren oder
das würde dafür zu finden und ein
letzter punkt gerade beim thema islam es
ist so dass versucht wird den islam als
religion zu verkehrlichen was will ich
damit sagen wir haben in deutschland das
staatskirchenrecht und man versucht die
religion als institutionen in die
universitäten als lehre aber auch bei
der religionsausübung so zu gestalten
wie man das von der kirche erkennt und
hier ist mein appell hört endlich auf
den die religion des islam so identisch
sehen zu wollen wie das christentum und
auch so institutionalisieren zu wollen
und lassen sie uns wirklich ehrlicher
darüber sprechen wie wir diese plurale
religion die sehr individualistisch ist
endlich ehrlich betrachten und wir
können wir schaffen wir können das
schaffen wenn wir aufhören immer in der
afg verhinderungs oder rechte
verhinderungspolitik sprechen wenn
menschen nicht mehr sich trauen und
wagen tatsächlich über
integrationsprobleme zu sprechen von
gewissen kreisen ohne die angst zu haben
jetzt werden alle migranten
kriminalisiert und man macht alle
muslime schlecht nein es gibt einfach
einen teil von menschen die nach
deutschland kommen die keinerlei
integrationswillen zeigen und leider
gottes sieht man das an verschiedenen
beispielen dieser brutalen wie der
ehrenmord der auch hier in bilder habe
ich hier ganz klar die studie rein
machen ja ich habe mich ja sehr auf ihr
thema heute vorbereitet
selbstverständlich und ich habe eine
umfrage gefunden die ja sehr spannend
finde auch den islam betreffen die
demokratie in deutschland und zwar die
kürzliche 1 bach umfrage hat gesagt dass
deutsche muslime die demokratie
positiver sehen als die
gesamtbevölkerung und zwar 81 prozent
der muslimischen bürger in deutschland
halten demokratie für die beste
staatsform in der gesamtbevölkerung sind
es nur 70 prozent nun von dieser studie
habe ich natürlich auch
gehört und bzw habe mit massiv auch
kürzlich darüber diskutiere arbeitet bei
uns und es kommt aus afghanistan familie
kommt aus afghanistan wie beide waren
sehr amüsiert darüber denn die 1b studie
60 prozent der hier in deutschland
lebenden wahlberechtigten türken haben
erdogan gewählt das sind die zahlen die
dagegen sprechen das heißt was hat er
jetzt ist ein miteinander das heißt dass
diese menschen sich hier lebend gegen
eine demokratie in ihrem heimatland
entschieden haben also sie die zahlen so
für sich allein gestellt überzeugen mich
nicht denn wenn jemand gefragt wird bist
du für die demokratie wenn du in diesem
land lebt dann glaube ich nicht dass sie
da ja so an sich haben in der
gesamtbevölkerung haben wir nur 70
prozent ja gesagt am selbe frage eins
bei den tieren ist übrigens schon sehr
jetzt hat man ja kein institut und wir
haben nur wir haben 81 prozent der
muslimischen bürger und nur 70 prozent
in der gesamtbevölkerung ja genau da
musste man aber immer das beispiel
türkei gegenstand ja ich rede von den
menschen die hier in deutschland leben
und auch das war ja ein aufschrei einer
der räume viel diskutiert es gibt
menschen hier in deutschland hier sind
wahlberechtigt für die türkei und sie
haben erdogan gewählt und es hieß also
es sind 60 prozent der hier lebenden
menschen wählen eine nicht demokratische
staatsform und wenn hatten wir nicht so
seit mehr als 30 jahren meine erfahrung
mit der muslimischen gemeinschaften wir
betrachten und ihre an den ganzen ärger
wir haben eine lieblingsseite ja sie
alle müssen sie ganz gut reinkommen
danke danke
ich habe wieder ein kleines problem
damit dass ich nicht verstehe warum
jetzt wirklich extrem komplexe themen
miteinander gemischt werden wir waren
bei afghanistan da machen wir weil
bekannten dann war mir bei migranten die
sich nicht integrieren wollen dann waren
wir bei der integrationsfähigkeit von
denen muslime sind wir bei türken die
erdogan will
das komplexe decken entschuldigung also
das ist schon in meiner hand ich dass
ich alles überhaupt
ein paralleler unterschiedliche komplett
parallele zwischen der
allensbach-umfrage und der türkei ist ja
die die türken in deutschland haben
maßgeblich dazu beigetragen dass die
parlamentarische demokratie
aber wir haben in der töpferei massiven
ich ging doch die türken in deutschland
ist es doch nein weil ich es geht doch
was genau ist das als beispiele aus ein
beispiel dafür dass die ansbach umfrage
mit vorsicht zu genießen ist denn die
haben überall so viel mehr in
deutschland war der anteil derjenigen
die damals mit ich weiß nicht ob man ja
oder nein abstimmen musste aber dann hat
er ja für das präsidialsystem abgestimmt
haben die haben mit die haben dazu
beigetragen dass erdogan krasse
durchgriffsrechte genau für das
präsidiale es war voll parlamentarische
demokratie jetzt gern auch und das zeigt
ja also und auch ein viel höherer
prozentsatz als in der türkei selbst und
das erreicht ja dass hier die in
deutschland lebenden türken für sozial
es ist nur ein anhand dieses beispiels
versuche ich zu erklären dass ich da
zweifel daran habe dass man durchweg
diese überzeugung haben könnte denn das
klingt ja so dass alle menschen die hier
in deutschland leben also immigranten
eigentlich sehr viel demokratischer sind
als die einheimische nur 100 bio
deutschen wie sie auch gerne genannt
werden das gibt das ja her und das
irritiert mich ganz einfach wenn ich mir
migrationspolitik und die realität der
menschen in parallel das ist als ganze
anschauen ich kleine stadt ihren also
oder oder ich verstehe ich glaube
[Musik]